Speaker 1: e of what happened when at the
shooting in Texas last week continues to
change. And both police and the school district
have stopped cooperating with the Texas probe,
raising all sorts of questions about what
on earth happened, including some less than
helpful speculation. And we'll talk about all of
it if there's one thing that we can be sure of,
if any talking point has been brutally destroyed
by what happened in Texas last week. It's the idea
of the good guy with the gun as the solution to
bad guys with guns. That has been utterly and
completely destroyed. But we still have to figure
out what is going on and why. It is not only that
the police and school district have stopped
cooperating with the Texas investigation, but
why the timeline put out there by police continues
to change. There's a CNN article addressing this.
As the funerals continue, authorities timeline
of the terror at Rob Elementary School continues
to shift. Continues to shift. The Texas Department
of Public Safety now says the door the shooter
used to access the school was closed but not
locked when he entered before killing 21 people
there. That's a change from last week when
the department's director said the back door
had been propped open by a teacher. Turns out
that apparently wasn't true. On Tuesday, its
spokesperson told the AP the teacher closed the
door when she realized the shooter was on campus,
but the door did not lock. The department's press
secretary confirmed yesterday to CNN that the AP
report was accurate. Tuesday's clarification
represents just one of the shifts in authorities
explanations of the massacres timeline. They face
mounting questions over why 80 minutes. We've
at first thought it was 40 to 60. We now know 80
minutes elapsed from the time officers were called
to the moment a tactical team entered the
locked classrooms and killed the gunman.
These are sort of like the main changes so far and
also important and unclear why. And we're going to
talk about this more on the bonus show is this
question of why the cooperation has stopped. ABC
News reporting Uvalde Police School District no
longer cooperating with Texas probe of shooting
the police department and Independent School
District Police force are no longer cooperating
with the Texas Department of Public
Safety as investigation into the massacre
at the elementary school. Multiple
law enforcement sources tell ABC.
The Valley Police chief and spokesperson for the
school district did not immediately respond for
requests for comment. According to sources, the
decision to stop cooperating occurred soon after
the directors of DPS, the director of DPS, held
a news conference Friday during which he said the
delayed police entry into the classroom was the
wrong decision and contrary to protocol. Something
clearly is going on here now. There are some who
are going way beyond what the facts show. I even
started to see. I hesitate to even mention
this, but I think it's important to mention
with the with the note that there's no evidence of
this, that some are saying this is evidence that
it might have actually been police that killed
some of the victims. There is no evidence of that
at this point in time. Absolutely none. But the
point is to let you know how far some are going in
interpreting the halt to the cooperation. The most
likely scenario is also the most obvious scenario,
which is the response was bungled. The good guys
with the guns didn't go in, at least partially
because they were afraid of being shot. With
which I sympathize, with which I sympathize.
But the whole point of having police is that
they are the good guys with guns to stop the
bad guys with guns. And waiting 80 minutes is
not the way the system is supposed to work. But
listen, who wouldn't be afraid of getting shot
if there's a gunman with multiple assault rifles
going crazy? That part makes sense. The response
does not. That's the most likely explanation,
that it was mishandled and they tried to stay one
step ahead of the questions that eventually came
because their explanations didn't make sense.
They failed to actually stay a step ahead,
and now it's all coming down. That's the most
likely explanation. The speculation is going
to be there regardless. But the most important
takeaway here as we get back to the main thing is
this is not going to be the problem of mass
shootings, is not going to be going to be
resolved by talking about mental health
alone. Obviously it's not. And in fact,
we'll later talk about how Greg Abbott says it's a
mental health issue but de-funded mental health in
Texas. Unbelievable. That's not going to solve
it. It's not going to be an issue with doors
and it's certainly not going to be an issue of
more armed people. At some point, you're going
to have to deal with the firearms. And we will
discuss more about this on today's bonus show.